what about now
oh hello this time it's
serious so
um I have um a confession to
make
in somewhere
2006 I have done something that I regret
something that I'm not proud of and I
would prefer to keep it as a
secret however being here today on this
stage with you all I honestly believe
that I should reveal
it in something in
2006 that I can only justify with lack
of
experience
I thought it would be a good idea to
learn Java however I think I was wrong
so many years later I'm a c developer
and I'm speaking at a festival to
another C developers about the
technology written in
Java so but I'm doing it because I
honestly believe that you are here
because you have been hearing about
Kafka you have seen that huge tech
companies use Kafka and you are curious
about it you want to understand how
Kafka can be useful to you as a
developer as someone that needs to build
an event driven application and likely
you couldn't find that talk for
you my name is g
f I know that g is really hard to
pronounce okay I'm Portuguese so feel
free to call me G and likely as you I
had to learn uh Kafka because I joined
the company with a newe event Ren
architecture and so I had learn it and
they use Kafka a
lot and during the process I done what I
usually do I went online and looked for
talks and most of the talks that I could
find I couldn't relate to them I
couldn't find a good example of what
type of concerns do I need to have by
building an event Ren architecture with
kka most of the things that I could find
were either a small example just sending
an a message or I would start with the
basics without knowing anything about
Kafka and by the end I was talking about
Kafka connect and Kafka streams that are
things that even nowadays I don't need
okay so I wanted to build that talk I
wanted to build a talk to answer that
those questions a talk that was most
about code that was most about stories
most about challenges that you face when
you are building a real example a real
world scenario so I have built some
applications A system that I have that
is currently in production and I want to
show you the code of that application
that relates to Kafka the challenges
that I faced I want to show you the
diagrams that I have to think the
problems that I have to solve and during
the process I will teach you the basics
of Kafka so I will not use slides I will
we will see a lot of code we will see
diagrams and I hope you feel comfortable
with that some housekeeping before if
anyone here has experience with Kafka
likely this session is not for you the
goal is if you are getting into Kafka
this session is is your starting point
so if you want to leave to another room
I will not take that personally okay so
feel free to to do
it and I told you that this talk is
based on a real world example and what
example is that
in last year August somewhere in August
I published my first YouTube video and
it started with a with a personal
challenge I'm not a native English
speaker as you already noticed for sure
and I have to find a way to keep
practicing it if you are not a native
speaker you know the challenge that it
is to speak two languages or even
more so I decided to start with YouTube
because of that and eventually I like
the process there's even one thing that
I really like on my YouTube channel that
I always show to everyone and I want to
show to you as
well if you go to
youtube.com and you search for GFA you
will not only see me doing some face
expressions that I didn't think that I
was capable of before starting this
thing but a YouTuber should do it right
and
also sometimes you will see that I'm
sharing the stage
with this amazing Brazilian singer it's
not me I promise and he has beautiful
music let me try to
place anyone here knows
Portugese you know so you know that this
is a music about making love right so
love songs the type of thing that you
don't get when you search for Nick
chapsas
online and by the way this Festival is
all about tech and music and I just gave
you both so I deserve a green card on
way out okay we agree on that perfect so
you might not notice let me see if you
can read I have
5.6 K of subscribers right so this is
not a lot obviously and it brings an
extra challenge that is how does this
thing will pay the bills the question
that one day being on the on the couch
my wife asked me how does this thing
will eventually pay the bills so being a
developer I answer in the best way that
I know I grabbed my laptop I open a
Google spreadsheet and I told her it
depends she didn't find that funny okay
she's not a consultant or knows anything
about software development so I had to
find another answer and the answer is on
that Circle that you can see right there
most content creators use Patron to earn
some money to justify the time that they
invest on this type of thing so I decid
to do the same thing but I wanted to do
it in a way that makes sense nowadays
that is not an experience of the past
that is something that makes sense in
2023 how by giving them access to my
GitHub organization I don't want to give
the experience to my patrons that they
un un download a zip file unzip it and
then they have the source code for my
videos but also I have a lot of ideas of
things that I could give them okay other
benefits but I had to start somewhere
and usually you start with your MVP and
this was my
MVP so I had a challenge to start you
can see there that Patron has an email
okay I have the email of the person that
is sponsoring me but also you can see
that on the other side GitHub will ask
me for an username okay if I want to
give you access I need your GitHub
username so I have a challenge here that
I have to solve I have to find a way to
my from one to the other one my first
idea was let me send an email to this
person ask him to go to a given form
leave the username and I will do the
rest okay I will add it to the GitHub
API so I have to solve this blackbox and
at the time I was learning about uh
Kafka so why not why not trying to
practice while I'm
learning and it looked like that cfco
would be a good choice because I could
spot that I have some events here the
logic of events will be here I have
patrons being activated patrons
cancelling all those things but also
this made sense in the perspective that
my architecture will keep growing with
new services so this was my starting
point and I faced a challenge right away
I went to patreon.com look for get for
the API documentation and it's a
fantastic API documentation if you like
if you like to be full okay if you don't
like to suffer don't use it to be honest
but they at least they have a good thing
they have web Books Okay and with a Web
book it means that they can call an HTTP
end point on my hand and then I can do
whatever I want so this is my starting
point
so what I decided to do was something
like this Patron will call a given HTTP
and point on my hand and what do I have
here is an HTTP trigger Azure function
okay I'm using serverless because I
don't have that much Lo okay and that
way it can be free so I start that way
and then I will send that information
right away to somewhere and since I was
studying cka why not
so the first question that I had to
answer was okay it's Kafka but where
okay how do I install CFA you can do it
with Docker you can install it in your
AWS account Azure whatever I decided to
use something that is called confluent
okay let me just log in because they are
always logging off and confluent
confluent cloud is basically a platform
as a service offer
for Kafka by the way while learning
Kafka if you can see that is really
expensive to handle this things uh By
the way when learnning CF you will see
the word confluent a lot really a lot
why there's a historical reason for that
kfka was first created at Linkin and
then some years later um some elements
of that
team went to cound this uh organization
the Confluence and the goal of
Confluence is to be basically the main
Steward of of Kafka is the way that I
see them but they invest a lot in the
community so you see a lot of talks from
people from confluent you see a lot of
libraries from them you see a lot of
things with the name confluent attached
I'm I don't work and I'm not affiliate
to them but I use the product mainly
because I don't have free time enough to
to record videos um what about patching
my gafa version right so I decide to go
with this software and here you can see
what I have I have a cluster so our
first concept of
Kafka they install it on Azure but that
in fact doesn't matter I will open it
and we'll get back here in a
moment you know the word cluster right
you have seen it on SQL Server things
like that but even on SQL Server you
don't write to the cluster right you
write to a table that is inside
somewhere in that cluster
what is the parallel on kfka the
equivalent concept is something that we
call an topic okay a
topic the way that I like to put it is a
kind of a log file okay where each line
is a message okay you can think about it
that way and what basically the term
that we us usually use is a commit loog
and then you will see that Kafka has
some particular uh particular particular
things that are really special for
example if you want to add a message to
Kafka you always add it to the end okay
you can't do other thing with it even if
you have a mistake for example on this
one you can fix it okay the only chance
that you have is to append something to
the end to fix it the same way as an
account balance if you need to correct
the balance because of a previous
movement you need to generate a new
movement why topics are immutable okay
the other thing that is special about
kfka is regarding those numbers that you
can see here
okay topics are in order you can see the
messages from start to finish in the
correct order okay and that is extremely
important as we will see in a few
minutes also they have a number right
and to that number we call the offset
okay the number is the offset keep that
in mind
so if we go into
confluent and let me just zoom out we
have here our topics so my first thing
was let me create my topic and when you
create a topic you have to provide a
name and also is asking me for something
named
partitions what is a
partition basically I like to you okay a
topic is not like a a simple log file
it's a distributed log file it's we call
it a distributed commit log why because
to have a complete topic you need to
join all the partitions the partitions
is the way that Kafka will spread
information across multiple Brokers what
are Brokers basically nodes in a server
in a cluster okay nodes or servers you
can think of them about them that way
this is really important because it's
that is this way that Kafka can be
extremely scalable it's because of this
that so many huge organizations like
PayPal Netflix and Linkedin it's because
of that that they use Kafka because you
can keep adding Brokers to your cluster
and adding partitions and you scale that
way so a partition is a portion of a
topic that means that when you send a
message to Kafka what will happen is
that the message will land for example
in Partition number two okay now that
you have the message on partition number
two likely will ask me but what if the
broker tool dies okay you have a problem
with it and now do you lose your
messages no basically if that happens
let's say that this one goes away you
still have those things that you can see
here so partition number two and
partition number two in Orange that we
call them replicas okay partitions have
replicas and to the ones in Orange we
call them followers to the ones in blue
we call them Lether so when you are
talking with kka you will connect to the
Lether you read and you write Theta into
leers and eventually the your replicas
will be refreshed with most recent Theta
and that way you might not lose datat
but we'll talk about that
later what will happen once you lose
Brook two is that cfco will start the
process that we call the leader election
and based on that leader election he
will decide which broker should now be
the leader okay is this partition ear or
this partition year in best position to
now become the leader so which one is
more accurate compared to what you are
expecting so now we know what is a topic
now we know what is a partition a
cluster right so I'm ready to start
implementing my think so I told you that
I have a nure function here that acts
with an HTTP trigger that will be
sending data into that thing on the
right
okay but how do I do it so this thing is
implemented with net and c and the
typical way of doing it in with C when
you search in Google uh you will be
redirected to this thing confluent once
again ca.net that is a a confluent
client a small library to connect to
Kafka okay this is the typical way
however this is not the way that I do
and I will show you the the one that I I
use there's nothing wrong about this
Library okay it's perfectly fine however
it's it's low level for me okay when you
are building an event driven
architecture everything is fine yeah um
when you are building buing an event
driven architecture you will notice that
most of your applications will keep
using the same stuff will keep doing
exactly the same things for example you
might have things to process data in
bches and you need to implement that
over and over again so I would like to
use this another one that is also open
source that is CFA flow and cka flow is
a a framework built on top of that one
that I just showed you so you can still
fall back into the other one and cka
flow has a lot of Advent Adventures at
least to me you will notice during my
presentation that you you will be using
a fluent way of describing your your
services what is good and also we'll see
some features that make it special that
are things that if you need to implement
by yourself it is a lot of work and we
will realize that once you apply to one
in an huge Network network of
applications you will see a lot of them
needing the same thing so it's a way of
simplifying your work but everything
that I will show you you can do it
either way you just need a bit of extra
of code if you
use this one
so keeping on how do I do it
with can you read it right on the back
yes okay sorry I didn't have the time to
to test um if we could read it well back
then but can you read it yeah anyone in
yeah perfect
so what I have done to to use this thing
cka flow I installed a n get package as
always and now what I we will need to do
is to go to your dependency injection
configuration it can be on your startup
program CS or for example in this case I
decided to extract um an extension
method okay and in this extension method
what I'm doing is just calling that
method F Kafka that is a method by Kafka
flow and then I will Define okay which
login provider do I want so basically if
I want to use the ey loger of Microsoft
if I want to use Cog those type of
things and then I will say how do I
connect to my cluster kind of the
connection string to Kafka okay so I
will use the data that Confluence Cloud
gave me and I will connect that way
then we have here another concept that I
need to explain as well while in you are
you might be familiar with something
like publish subscribe right Pub sub so
when you send data to somewhere you are
a publisher when you read you are a
subscriber in kfka they have different
names so when you are sending data to a
topic you are producing data so you are
a producer when you are consuming data
you are a consumer so keep that in mind
and that is a kind of a role that an
application will have when connecting to
your topic so in this case what I have
done is say okay this application is a
producer and that producer has this name
that I will use in a moment and also
please by default write to this topic if
I will if I want to write to a different
place I will let you
know and then since I don't have a lot
of money please apply compression okay
by default Kafka doesn't apply
compression to messages however if you
apply compression you are saving in
network and also in storage okay there's
multiple types of compression types um
gzip uh I need to see them I always
forget but you okay there's four or five
but when you when you use compression
type you are basically doing a tradeoff
between the CPU time that will'll take
to compress that thing okay in read and
write time so you need to take those
decisions CF is mostly about tradeoffs
okay it's mostly about that gzip does an
excellent job to compress things but you
always need to think about those things
as you have seen with just those few
lines of code I have defined my
relationship of my Azure function with
uh Kafka okay so now the only thing that
I need to do is when whereever ever I
want to produce that message to send
that message I just need to to call a a
simple method and I have that here so
you will notice here that I'm getting
through dependency injection something
that Kafka will keep me Kafka flow and
then I'm getting from there the producer
with the name that I just configured
then the only thing that I will need to
do is right here is okay please produce
this message that is right here
now you might ask what is a message
right and that is a good question
because I didn't explain that yet if we
go into I will use now another
application but you can see this as well
on confluent CL however if you are in
Kafka take a look into conductor with a
with a K and um it's has an amazing um
experience to to the
developers and let me open here one
topic this that I'm opening now is a
topic
loading loading loading time for
water okay and here you can see three
messages and messages have just a few
types of things inside let's start by
the value this thing that you can see
right here as a
Json
okay don't think that it needs to be
adjacent it doesn't Okay Kafka wants uh
bites okay Kafka doesn't want Chason
doesn't want uh protuff doesn't want any
of those things and that is also the
beauty of Kafka because now you can
bring Kafka to support an event driven
architecture and everyone is producing
events and things like that then your
data team wants to bring some technology
to ingest that data into somewhere and
they are not locked in to given protocol
okay CFA can grow with your business
because of this type of things things so
is also part of the Bea of it in this
case it's Json because it was the way
that I serialized the data okay it could
be another thing the other thing that a
message has is um a key value pair with
others okay kind of like um HTTP request
you have the others you can use them to
simple things like um correlation IDs uh
message types things like that there's
metadata where you can see that that
offset that I told you it's here so this
is the message with offset number eight
okay uh but there's other information
like the partition where it is currently
dates and things like that but the most
important one that I want to to pay
attention when you are designing your
system with kfka is the key the key is
really important to take a good decision
when you start with this thing let me
show you the source code again
did you notice here that I'm in message
key I'm sending the email or uh default
text that is unknown and why I'm doing
that because basically um I I'm using
the unknown because I don't trust their
Belo that do documentation was lying to
me so I will just have this as a kind of
fallback but I'm using the email for a
simple reason imagine that that I get a
an event from um Patron saying okay this
Patron has paid successfully his
membership okay so for me now this
person is active then few moments later
I get another one saying the membership
was cancelled now imagine that I process
them in the other way around okay the
output of the system is
different and I told you that in a topic
messages are in order right however when
you are consuming them
you can only consume them them in order
if by partition so you need to ensure
that every single message that for a
given context that needs to be processed
in order that lands exactly in the same
partition that is really important so
imagine the following scenario I'm
sending a message the first message that
I told you that goes here and the other
one goes here now who's reading this
thing since this thing is scaling with
through multiple servers I can process
them in different orders when I set the
email Kafka will use a thing that we
call the
distribution um uh distribution uh
strategy yeah this strategy that they
call it and the distribution strategy
will basically apply an ash on top of
the email and based on that hash we'll
calculate that okay this one should go
here okay so every single time that I
send exactly the same message key it
will go always into the same partition
it's a way of making sure that that
happen now you might ask what if I don't
care about that the only thing that I
want is to produce messages okay I don't
care about the order just set the
partition the message key to null and on
that case what Kafka will do is to apply
a round robing strategy so it's the most
efficient way for throughput of your
system okay first goes to the first
partition then to the second then to the
third then gets back to the to the
beginning always like that so defining
the correct message key is really
important it's important to think about
that when you are building your first
system okay so now in our
application I'm getting an event from
Patron I'm processing with an HTTP
trigger and I'm sending the message to
kfka perfect now I need to handle that
message I need to transform it into
something that has a meaning to me
because as you can see here what I'm
getting is a huge payload with a lot of
information that doesn't say anything to
me and the message type that I get from
them is like new member member updated
member deleted okay just that and the
member updated might be a lot of things
might be that it was play successfully
uh the card was invalid or the person
decid to cancel the the membership a lot
of things so I I need to find to convert
all all that information into something
that has meaning meaning to me so what I
decided to do was to bring another
application okay by the way this is not
a talk on how to avoid over engineering
okay so what I've done is that I created
that Pon manager that has an internal
State and based on the input you will
calculate what changed and based on what
changed I know is a a new Patron that I
need to give access that I need to send
the email or is someone that I need to
revoke the assess and when I know that I
will publish into ear into another topic
that is specific for this type of the
main events the one on the right we'll
talk about that later one thing that
you'll notice here is that first for the
first time we have a consumer a consumer
is something that reads data remember
that but you also notice that this
application plays multiple roles okay he
is not only a consumer is also producer
producer so an application can have
multiple producers or multiple consumers
so don't think about kfka as only a
technology to connect tiny Mei
microservices as you see on Netflix okay
so it's not about that an application
can play multiple roles and since in
this case the domain is that it made a
lot of sense to me and what does this
application as of special okay let's
take a look into the s code move
into the patron manager that is right
here okay and now what you should notice
here is that besides the add cluster
thing that I showed you okay we have
seen this already I also have the add
consumer so it's not a producer is a
consumer and when I have a consumer I
need to say a few things for example I
need to say which topic I'm consuming
okay where I will be looking at to get
new messages I give it a name this is
useful for operations if you want to see
in some dashboards and things like that
this group ID let's leave it for a while
we'll get back to it this workers and
buffer thing is one of my favorite
features of Kafka flow why because I
told you that CF is highly scalable
right you can bring more Brokers and
partitions so you have more con
consumers reading them but often you
will notice that you will have a single
application that is handling message
after message but your topic the leg of
the topic the number of message to
process keeps growing and you see that
the resources of that application are
not being used like memory or CPU so you
want to take advantage of those with
workers basically CF flow does multi-
threading for you but does it in a way
that preserves the order of the messages
where is is really challenging but
extremely useful so it's one of those
small details with a single line that
you you have for free with CF flow also
I'm saying here please read everything
from the
beginning I told you that messages are
in order in the topic right that means
that if you go to the beginning of the
topic you can start rebuilding a
complete data store for your application
because one important thing about afka
is that on that topic when I read the
message I'm not working like a queue in
a queue when you read you get the
message out so the message is gone no
one can read it again while in kfka
those two things are the coupled the
process of reading and the process of
deleted are two different things
messages might be deleted one day but
they might be okay we'll talk about that
later but that is one of those small
details that make gafka extremely
efficient you you know that the cheapest
thing to do with iio is to always write
things to to the dis instead of deleting
of changing
them okay so I'm saying please read it
from the beginning so what happened in
my application is that the first time
that I started this thing that I
deployed it it went to the first message
coming from patreon that I already had
on my topic reveal everything if now I
need to delete the store that I'm using
I just need to start it again we reset
the offset to the beginning and it will
replay every single thing it's a
avilable thing to do and also you will
see that CFA flow has here an option
that is called middle
Wares if anyone here has ever used
something like um mediator you are
familiar with this concept the concept
of a pipeline of a Shain of
responsibility basically cka flow gives
you a way to create a pipeline where a
message goes into the first middle midw
that middleware can handle it can
transform it can do whatever he wants
and then deliver it to the next one okay
and so on and so forth as As You Wish
okay it's like um Lego blocks that you
will pie them in the way that you want
and what I'm doing here is as simple as
saying okay the message is coming out of
the topic and as I told you Kafka only
works with uh bytes so I need to
transform that into the type system so I
will need to this realize that thing so
I'm using a serializer using Newton soft
there's a lot of them available right
there like um protobuf and message pack
and others they are right there by
default and once serializer runs by the
end I will have a message type okay an
object that represents that message so I
will deliver that message to A type
thler and that type thler will do a
simple thing like you know on mediator
okay this message is for example a
patron updated event so please handle it
dear class Patron updated event handler
okay as simple as that so now the only
thing that you need to do is to go to
that source code and implement the logic
so one of the beauty of this is that
through the configuration of your system
you describe the complete relationship
with cka then I just need to focus on
writing my code the code that will send
email the code that will do whatever I
want okay and this is usually the
hardest part when working with lowlevel
libraries the other thing that I told
you is that this application is not only
a consumer as we see here he has another
roles like another consumer or for
example a producer and this producer has
one different thing from the other ones
that is this with X that is is extremely
important in Kafka if we go here and we
click we'll see that we can do it as a n
Lether or all what is this thing X you
can um consider them
acknowledgements and let me go into the
partitions diagram that will
help I see Kafka as an ibath between a
database and a messaging system and you
have all the options to configure if you
want it to be more one of them or the
other one there's a lot of tradeoffs on
your
decisions and one of the decisions is
this acknowledgement thing why when you
send a
message it goes here okay and if I set
acknowledgements To None what will
happen is that I I know that I send the
message okay and I will get the response
but response will say successful even if
the message is not yet stored on that
partition okay so I might lose data this
is it might sound strange but if you are
building for example A system that is
based on Telemetry to monitor some
things you might consider to lose some
data um and the tradeoff is performance
so this is the most efficient way the
most F the fastest way to write data
into CF okay with an N however let's say
that I'm I don't want that and I want at
least to make sure that the data is
already in the partition so the data
will go into the the Leer partition one
and then once get back I will be able to
see if it was committed into the
partition successful successfully or
not what if it is there but I lose that
broker and replicas are not in sync I
lose later once again but I don't want
to lose those account movements things
like that so so I can set the
acknowledgements to all and by doing
that what will happen go to the Lether
those ones need to be in sync and only
then I get the answer back saying we
have it okay we will not lose it okay so
obviously this last one will take more
time and if you need that huge
speed you you know that you have a
tradeoff to to make here so this is why
I say that you it's kind of an IBD
between uh multiple things multiple
decisions that you will take another
thing that I wanted to share with you is
that with Kafka you you can do bch
processing okay you can produce things
in botch and read them in bch and you
can do a bch with multiple topics uh
that is another trade-off that you can
have if you want to latency if you want
the the throughput of your system if uh
the time that takes to process a single
message is important to you you can
decide to use bch or not all of those
things okay getting back into our
diagram so now what is happening here is
that someone is a new Patron call it the
HTTP endpoint I store that in the given
place by the way this is an excellent
strategy if you don't trust third
parties because if something goes wrong
on that API if they refresh it if they
do a mistake I already have the event SE
here on my hand okay so if something
goes wrong when I'm ingesting them on my
patreon manager I can handle it later
okay it's it's on my control and I don't
trust them so is what I'm doing so now I
I'm producing events into this one
saying okay I have a new Patron and it
has been activated so let's handle that
thing I told you that my goal is to send
an email right simple just create
another consumer now you know how to do
it that consum consumer will consume
that um topic and then I will react to
it to send an email using SMTP I'm using
send gri you can do whatever you
want however there's an really important
detail here first time that I deploy
this thing into production what happened
is that a friend that was a patron told
me that he was getting um duplicated
emails from me okay so I had to take a
look on that and I realized that it's
because
Kafka is the concept of deliver at least
once so Kafka will make sure that you
get the message but it doesn't promise
you that you only have one okay so we
will try to send it back if is not
sure so what do you need on this case
you need iony in your system is another
concept that is really important to
think about on this type of system okay
have some way to the duplicate messages
okay sometimes it can be easy like in
this case like a simple table saying if
I already sent the email to this person
or not okay other times it might be bit
harder to do but always think about that
how you will duplicate those messages
it's highly
important so I'm sending those emails
those emails contain a link the link
will redirect them to another
application that is a web application
that has a form on that form you have a
field to set your GitHub username first
implementation that I've done let me
call the GitHub
API however it was not a good idea why
not not sure if you know but the gab API
has throttling and you can do only a
small set of requests per hour okay uh
not that I have that many a huge number
of patrons however when you are testing
and things like that you will notice
that the other thing is that the API
might be down or worse that happened to
me I forgot to to refresh my access
token so someone went there typed the
kab username click error try again click
error don't try again okay so I lose a
patron by that so what I decide to do is
to instead okay I'm using CF why I don't
write it to a different topic and I
could and I can handle it later if the
gab API is down no problem I can run my
consumer later
and this is another cool thing because
now I can scale and I can have a
different throughput on either on my
producers or on my consumers I can take
those decisions so what I've built is
another consumer you can see it's always
the same pattern producers and consumers
and by the way this application has a
producer to write into here and on this
one what I'm doing is that okay let me
call the GitHub API perfect but you will
notice that I have two arrows getting
out of that topic how's that
possible this is another thing that
everyone values on Kafka while in a
message queue the message is processed
by someone and no one else will look at
it right in Kafka you can consume the
same message with multiple intents for
example the intent of this application
this one gab Patron
manager okay is to call the gab API to
give access however I have this other
application that maintains an internal
stage internal picture of my patrons why
if I need to recover something if I need
to do something manually I can always do
it so I need to read exactly the same
message twice one for one application
and the other one to the other one and
now do we do do that you might remember
that year when I'm was talking about the
the consumers I skip this group ID this
is the concept of U consumer groups the
consumer group it's like a role that an
application is is um playing inside of
your inside of your system so you can
have multiple instances of a of
consumers so multiple consumers but they
all play a single role the way that I
like to explain this is with the example
of a book okay imagine that I'm reading
this book so and imagine that this book
is a topic okay each page on the book is
a message okay the number of the page is
the offset okay so now when I'm reading
okay uh let's say that I bookmark on
page 50 let's say keep the bookmark
there I know that last message that I've
read was was the page 5050 so I can
leave the book go do other stuff get
back in the mouth and I know what I left
off it's like exactly the same concept
as kavka so when I finish to read the
given message I can commit my offset
last one that I that I just read and I
told you that this one of the dark side
is mine so I'm reading this thing that
doesn't mean that someone else in my
home can pick the same book and read it
as well for example let's say that this
another one is the bookmark of the
bathtime story of my daughter because
she falls asleep when I talk about t Ren
development
and since it's the bedtime story is for
her for the purpose of she falling
asleep okay but doesn't mean that she
needs to read it I can grab the book and
I know that we left on page 90 something
like that I read this few pages this
night okay and then I committed again
right I have the bookmark there I leave
the book next day my wife will come she
will open the book she will see okay so
they left on this page she doesn't need
to know the previous Pages the story
behind she just needs to read the
following ones the following messages
committed again leave the book we are
both working on a consumer group it's
basically that okay and the beauty of it
is that I don't need to carry a Post-It
note with me saying I left this on on
page 100 yesterday right that
information is inside of the book inside
of the topic with Kafka we store that
without doing any effort by the way in
something that is called zookeeper or um
nowadays there's a way of doing it
inside of a topic
itself and the same thing is happening
here I have two applications working
with two different consumer groups so
they will consume the same message you
can even see that on your or
applications that connect to Kafka when
you are managing that or for example
this one is the so let me go to Pro and
if we go here into consumer groups you
will see that I have two applications
that play two different roles connected
to the same exactly topic okay so we'll
process the same messages you will also
see an overall lag what is this Kafka
will tell me how many messages each
consumer still needs to process So
currently they are all in the last
message so they don't have anything to
do but if I produce now a lot of
messages they might go in different
speeds so one in a few minutes might
have a leg of 50 and the other one might
be in zero once again same thing with
books okay I still have 100 pages to
read it's my offset leg basically
that this means that if in my
architecture I need to bring now
something like a mailing list okay let's
say that I want a new mailing list and
what I will do is okay let's say that
this represents my mailing list it to me
it will be as simple as having another
application here that is consuming
exactly the same events and calling that
to this we tend to call an evolutionary
architecture I don't need to touch the
existing pieces right I just keep adding
features and obviously this will sound
ridiculous to you because we are talking
about a single guy with 5K subscribers
and 10 patrons or something like that so
over engineering however imagine this in
a newe organization where someone is
producing to a topic the date of your
clients and marketing wants it Logistics
wants it everyone wants it and everyone
needs to read exactly the same things
and they don't want to be waiting for
each other okay so that that's the
goal last thing that I want to to show
you remember that I told you about this
thing that we'll talk about that
later this thing is a snapshot so every
single time that I send a message into
with the domain event to the other side
I also want to send here a picture of
the current state of that Patron why
imagine that I want to export something
like a CSV file or I want to create an
application to run something like a
ruffle to give some prizes things like
that and I want to connect to something
that looks like a table okay make
sense another example that you can think
about is for imagine that in your
company there's a service that is
responsible by customers or clients
addresses okay so to the rest of the
organization previous versions of your
of the addresses of those clients
doesn't matter what it matters is the
last one and you want that
picture so how do we do that let me go
back here and remember that I told you
that the process of um reading and
deleting data was decoupled they were
two different things that happens
because when you are creating a
topic let me just zoom in for your
benefit you will not only need to to say
the topic and the partition but you can
also Define a cleanup
policy by default Kafka will do a
strategy of deleting all data when some
conditions are met for example time or
the the size of the topic and Kafka
wants to do this to keep optimizing
itself okay ideally you have this
however if you need it play carefully
you can do this okay it can be there
forever okay up to
you however this might be for example
extremely useful if you have something
like this message as pii uh protected
identify information something like that
personal identifi information and due to
gdpr you want to delete that data after
one year okay cka can do it for you for
example however there's something here
that is strange to me but I'm using on
that topic itself that is the strategy
of
compact compact doesn't look a natural
thing to me to be honest but makes a lot
of sense I told you that the message key
plays an important role in CFA it's not
only because you need to make sure that
messages are processed in order in a
given uh place it is also when you need
to do this compact thing the compact is
useful for cases like this where only
the last last picture only the last
message matters for from now on okay the
oldest versions of that address the old
oldest versions of that Patron doesn't
matter it will basically do a kind of a
distinct inside of your topic does that
mean that you always have a single
message of per message key inside of a
topic no it doesn't mean that it means
that when it runs it will up imize by
deleting the oldest versions of that
message key so if everyone if anyone now
goes and points the application to the
first message and reprocess everything
you will capture only one version of
that message okay but you are not
assured that that will
happen
so during this hour I have told you
about the challenges that you face when
you are building this type of
application
I told you the the basic concepts of
what is a topic what is a partition what
you need to think about what is a
producer what is a consumer there's
other things more in Kafka there's
things like streams there's things like
Kafka connect there's things like a
schema registry okay but honestly
everything that you have seen today is
what you need to do your first diligence
to understand if CF is useful for you to
go to a job interview VI and someone
asks you something about Kafka and at
least you have some ideas of all that is
useful okay it's enough to to have the
basic knowledge of what CF is because
even things like streams are built on
top of these Concepts okay so I hope
that you learned something today and I
hope that you enjoyed this session by
the way the first one coming to ask a
question we'll take a prize from
Portugal okay and thank you auri